[Music]
what's up dickies it is monday morning
10 a.m coming in fresh
off the plane from nashville tennessee
what's up thickie stickers the gums
thicker rats
whatever you want to call yourselves
what's going on fam um yeah fresh off
the plane from nashville tennessee one
of my favorite spots
one of my absolute favorite spots
uh nashville was freezing nashville was
started dumping snow we got there on
thursday it was like 75
then friday just decided to start
dumping snow snow everywhere
um love nasford though zanny's one of
the greatest clubs in all of the
earth i won't go that extreme with it um
it was great man it was freaking great
of course of course
my boy jelly roll showed up and just
he's such a dynamic charismatic dude he
got every and i told everybody i told
everybody
the whole crew so jeff dies there theo's
there obviously theo doesn't drink but
jeff dye
theo
uh david lucas my brother
everybody this the opener we had there i
said
jelly is
is such a fun guy such a fun time but
he's gonna force you to drink you gotta
be able to tell him no otherwise
everybody out here is gonna end up
throwing up you gotta be able to turn
down the shots that he's gonna make you
take
and i know the game so uh
you know i i had to get up the next one
at 8 am because i did bust it with the
boys at 9 00 am
and then the debut of tiger thick
whiskey
was um
also in nashville so um i had to do a
signing for the our biggest distributor
there
so i uh
you know i took it easy drinking with
jelly went to the soho house after and
he just i mean he's buying 40 shots dude
i'm like dude jelly there's six of us
man who's drinking this [ __ ]
and he just you know jelly being jelly
david lucas learned the hard way david
luke's brother learned the hard way jeff
dye learned the hard way my brother
learned the hard way and jay would not
jay should know jay should know but
jelly is a freaking force man he's just
a freaking force so good to see him
his song that's on octane on sirius it's
like you know how when adele comes out
with a song you're like after after two
weeks like all right quit playing this
goddamn song that's where jelly's at
right now there's a huge country song
out right now it's all over he's just
blowing up yeah
and then jelly what jelly wants to do
he's going to start doing uh a podcast
which i'm going to help him out with
that might be on the thick boy but
um
help him out with this pot he wants to
do
and then jelly also wants to start uh
helping
musical talent out and jelly pitched me
for an hour chin on you being his guy
that's so trippy yeah he was like if i'm
banking on anybody it's chin i was like
really i was like i love chin but really
goes yeah man i'm telling he can do it
he's been so supportive yeah he's like
he's like i'm telling you chin's all
right or die he can do it i was like all
right dude let's freaking let's do it
let's go asian country singer and i said
but joe you can't make him too famous
because he's going to quit nah never
leave a kid in the shop show and
companion
so we're trying to figure it out but
busting with the boys uh
taylor and will compton
these guys just changing the goddamn
game man changing the freaking game with
what they're doing what they're doing is
you know obviously uh will and taylor
taylor you know pro ball tackle
got hurt uh the year before played this
year we're coming back in a time
superstar man the nfl like bonafide
superstar but him and will compton
started this busting with the boys they
signed with barstool sports so they're
they are bar stool product their
contracts happen pretty soon here so
we'll see about that but uh what they do
is they take that bus and they go to
college campuses so they went to
nebraska they're in michigan on friday
uh they're trying to get in with alabama
and they they talk with the kids and the
coach and nobody's doing it man and it's
a game changer those boys are blowing
the hell up blowing up they came to the
shows it was just a great time man
that's
such good friends in nashville
with that weather and everything going
down i realized could never live there
it is freezing it was freezing man
absolutely freezing but uh yeah jelly is
just
all everybody jelly theo's out there was
just such a fun time christa stefano is
out there he's doing the ryman theater
he got done with the show raced over to
me
um
it was just a great time man it was just
a freaking great time out shout out to
nashville
one of the best clubs in all of the
all the country man it's just a grand
old time a grand old time
your boy uh cheated on his diet for the
first time last night and
dude my stomach is on the fritz my girl
made her mexican cooking when i got home
and it is on the frickin fritz dude it
is not fun right now my stomach is in
knots but we'll figure it out great way
to kick off your birthday week [ __ ]
your pants so that's fun
b day is friday not big on b days i like
other people's b days i think my son's
more excited for my birthday than i am
because he knows there's gonna be cake
even though i'm he'll eat the cake
that's all he cares about
so also first day uh for my son's school
without mask
kids are without math finally man we're
getting back to it dude how about you
know china's locked down
locked down locked down they're trying
to do a zero covet thing
so they want no code results and there's
like i think 200 people or 300 people
got it the omni crown there lock down
some parts trying to lock the [ __ ] down
lock lock down yeah scary right
not cool man not cool
but uh yeah shout out to nashville great
time
let's get into fights um
i'm so excited man this weekend this
saturday at 1 p.m we have a calabasas
fight campaign for the ufc london it's
been three freaking years finally the o2
arena the legendary o2 arena is back
um
when they announce this i blast out on
my social media i'm proud of london
getting their [ __ ] together and you know
there's nothing like a a british crowd
man there's nowhere there's nowhere else
like it i don't care where you go
they're they're the best crowds the it's
electric
and this card is filled
filled with some of the top uh european
talent especially out of england man and
it's stacked from top to bottom and it's
so stacked we decided to do a cowbest
fight companion for it and i just can't
wait man i'm excited to my favorite
fighters on this card you guys know i'm
ride or die for british fighters being
half english mama born and raised there
so
i'm looking forward to this one man so
we're doing a cowbest fight company at
1pm this saturday crystalia jeff dye
myself
and uh wait do you see the graphic that
my boy ruben made for it it is lit liddy
like a titty y'all litty like a freaking
titty
but uh
[Music]
i'm just so excited that it's you know
on and popping at the o2 arena and boy
did they have a great card for you you
know
fight campaigns really only for the big
pay-per-views but
this should really be a pay-per-view and
the the ufc's
really giving us a treat making this a
free fight night um although it'd be
nighttime in london it's the middle of
the day for us here in the states um but
you're you're the main card is from top
to bottom i think there's 10 uh uh
british fighters on here and it's like
the big boys you know you kick off with
tom aspinall who
really you know obviously patty patty
the baddie is kind of the the face of
european fighting right now uh even
though he has one fight in ufc has a lot
of similarities to connor um in regards
to the hype
the charisma the x the x factor patty
the baddie has that i mean that's why he
signed with bar stool makes seven-figure
deal with barstool sports um i don't
know what they've been doing with them
i'm sure they're gonna release content
this week with patty i would assume
that's part of the deal
but you know
outside patting the hype on paddy you
look at a guy like arnold allen who
hasn't you know
he's out of tri-star
with frost but due to the covet
protocols and lockdown stuff like that
he's had to keep his camp in london but
arnold allen i mean i think he's not
he's won nine in a row and he gets uh
dan hooker who's cutting down uh to
featherweight
you know so for arnold this is a fight
where you beat a guy like dan hooker you
know you're cracking top five it's off
to the races and he deserves it man a
guy of his caliber who's good at every
freaking thing stand-ups ridiculous uh
ground games no slouch you know
obviously dan hooker
and i hate when it's two guys that i
that i i love arnold allen i loved and i
absolutely love dan hooker um but this
is a tough tough tough assignment for
dan hooker to fight arnold allen o2
arena with a london crowd at his back
um you know there's a reason arnold
allen's won nine in a row
there's a reason for it this is a huge
step up he's the co-main event um o2
arena so
you know i'll see him be biased man as
much as i love dan hooker i want to see
the london boys get it done and because
that crowd's going to be absolutely
insane uh you know there's a reason
michael bisbee never lost on his home
soil never lost and you know you hear
him talk he talks about you know the
just the energy and the
the
the insane chaos that that london crowd
brings it just brought him to another
level he never lost it never lost on his
home soil so i think there's something
to be said for that um you know with the
main event with tom aspen on uh volkov
you know nothing's i always tell you
guys this nothing's better than a
fighter's come up and a guy
you know if you want to watch this come
up obviously patty's fun to watch arnold
allen's been doing the goddamn thing um
before i get into tom arnold allen's
interesting so
genetically is a complete [ __ ] freak
i think his brother is a strong man and
his dad's a strong man
so obviously
you know when you look at dan hook
you're like oh bigger guy come down to
featherweight he's going to have a size
and strength advantage i think he i
think he's me surprised how [ __ ]
strong arnold allen is with those
genetics man he's a freak dude he's a
freak that's he freaks in his family
strong man you know freaking strong
those guys are his brother and dad must
be enormous they must be freaking
enormous dude
uh allen's just fine with suspension
plead guilty all right and a brawl
that's how sometimes that happens yeah
um
yeah bring up his uh dad and brother
though
strong man what
oh they're there
i recall's being warned off steroids
my strong man father is a child
he always says that his dad takes a ton
of
oh i mean yeah that's that's part of the
game yeah
uh
says strongman father injected so
although some people took exceptions
comments about his former strongman
father injecting since i was a baby alan
assists that his father's history with
pd's has always been a source of humor
within the family household
despite some negative reactions almighty
didn't lament heaven laugh at his
father's expense following this
particular camp spectacular comeback
submission victory
but i don't regret it it's a joke me and
my dad have always had
when we were growing up since the early
2000s he was taking a lot of steroids
when he was doing the strongmen events
it was just a culture they were involved
in they were all taking steroids yeah
they still do yeah uh allen remembers
witness his father taking steroids as a
child but also recalled his father worn
him away from substances i'd walk in his
room and he was injecting he was always
very open about it that's that's good
he was always very against me and my
brother using anything he'd always be
like look i don't want you guys doing
this [ __ ] it will ruin your life and
you'll depend on it yeah he always told
us uh not like we ever wanted to try but
we've always made jokes about it with
him we make jokes about him being angry
because on steroids like the angry
dinners because of steroids i know some
people don't get the joke especially
american guys watching us english making
jokes different i think everyone that's
english gets it i think most americans
get it but we like to get riled up over
nothing because it gives a lot of these
dummy something to do he goes no i don't
think it's [ __ ] up i just think it was
messed up i'd be like what are you doing
man
even alan's brother who competes in
strongman events hasn't followed his
father's footsteps on kim's pd's he does
do strong man bobby honestly he's
terrified of needles i think they've
tried to give him stuff but he can't
because he's too scared
interesting outside uh usada have no
have not contacted him since making the
comments
but he hopes they do they haven't come
knocking yet but i hope they do i've
never been tested in england i've never
been tested back home bring them the
more the merrier yeah
isn't that interesting though
cage fighter and your dad and brother
are strong man
dude he's a savage nine in a row you
know how hard that is at this level
he beats dan hooker but you know people
think dan hooker being the bigger taller
guy coming in is going to have the
strength advantage with those genetics
man even though his papis on steroids
you know this
you know you guys are giving too much
too much emphasis on the steroids you
know all those guys are doing it but
obviously genetically arnold allen is a
complete [ __ ] freak
college basketball fans oh my god you
guys are foaming at the nose it's march
madness and join the action on the court
during the biggest tournament of the
year we talk about the march madness
baby draftking sportsbook turn your
team's victory into your own big win new
customers can bet just five dollars on
any team to win and get 200 dollars in
free bets if they do it's that freaking
simple if they win you win if sportsbook
isn't available in your state yet you
can still join man the college hoops is
going down with draftkings pools
everyone can play free pools all march
long for a shot at a share over 250
thousand dollars in prizes simply join a
pool and answer questions like who will
make it to the next round who will hit
the most three pointers then track your
results download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use the promo
code shop s-h-a-u-b bet five dollars on
any college hoops team to win and get
two hundred dollars in free bets if they
do if they win you win with the promo
code shop this week at draftking
sportsbook 21 or older restrictions by
sea show notes for details you can also
bet on the ufc fight night in london
baby we're doing cal bass fight campaign
for the london card at the o2 arena if
you're going to bet on the fights do it
with the best in the biz the official
sportswearing partner the ufc talking
about draftkings use promo code shobb
all right that's shobb this week at
draftking sportsbook to the main event i
also think uh the the fight of the night
is gonna be arnold allen dan hooker or
it's gonna be krylov versus paul craig
one of those is gonna be fight the night
but arnold allen dan hooker is a
fantastic fight
fantastic
uh main event though tom aspinall is an
interesting one tom aspinall uh first
team all dad talked about his kids
non-stop um
you know
the question for
uh aspinall
is can he
you know would what's he have one with
the c he has one two three so he's 4-0
in the ufc one fight went out the set
the first round it was only a minute and
that was andre arlovski
tough customer that's a tough night in
the office arlovski is very tough to
beat especially to finish and he uh rear
naked choked andre arlovski
but with tom it's not his fault with tom
coming up in this game especially at the
ufc level
uh he's he's been fighting he's a he's a
coveted baby he's a coveted baby so
you know kids that grew up grow up in
this covid time even though it's over
now and shout out to my kids school for
not having maths today thank god
but for tom aspinall he's a coveted baby
meaning he's never had to fight in front
of big crowds where the pressure is
really amplified so for him for your
first big crowd fight to be in your
backyard the o2 arena and you're the
main event not only the main event
you're fighting volkov who's the number
six heavyweight in the world and is
impossible to finish dude he's a tough
[ __ ] customer man
but you know
at heavyweight when you're foreign
you're starching dudes and you look at
tom's last opponent who fought i think
last weekend and uh beat greg hardy so
it shows you how good tom is
um and also
that fight show me how good thomas but
deandre alofsky really showed me
so for tom when you're heavyweight and
you're foreign you know
you haven't had any really
uh speed bumps at all
there's only one way to go you can get a
top tank diet heavyweight it's just the
roster's not deep enough
and you know tom talks about it being
faster than he wanted to you know
getting to this level and he you can
tell he's a very cerebral guy most guys
who are black belts and jitsu you know
his background is jiu jitsu he's a he's
a beast on the ground
so
to get a black belt you got to be
you're you're going to be a little more
of a cerebral fighter than than a lot of
the guys who just do boxing or stand up
to get in the game or even wrestling
usually just you guys are a little more
uh higher iq when it comes to the fight
game and tom's one of those guys so i
don't think
uh the moments can be too big for him
you know he talks about even when he's a
kid his his trainers and stuff they
would you know visualize this and think
about it and so i even though it's
fascinating wanted to i just think it's
the right call and when you're starching
guys like this the ufc's like alright
dude we gotta throw you a dog you got a
dog in volkov
and again it's one of those fights where
seeing me being biased i love volkov
train with volkov great guy one of the
nice guys in the ufc phenomenal athlete
you know former world champ from
bellator has had a great career in the
ufc um should it be derek lewis but then
making some mistakes got knocked out
with a minute left or whatever two
minutes left in the fifth round
but you know volkov um
you know
they're not doing tom aspinall any
favors here because volkov has been in
the big fights he was a main event uh in
london i think we beat verdum he's a
main event um
and he's no stranger to five rounds so
for tom
you know if you're betting on this fight
i don't know what the odds are we can
look them up but
you know for tom it's your first fight
uh big main uh card fight first five
round fight
london o2 arena the crowd is gonna be
[ __ ] electric which he's never
even taste you know this is the first
time he's ever gonna see something like
this
volkov you know he's talking about a
real vet dude a guy who's been in main
events he's been five rounds he's been
there with the best he's beat the best
he's lost to the best volkov is a minus
120. a small is a plus 100 and that's
fair going off the experience of volkov
you know the biggest knock on tom
aspinall is experience his only way to
get experience that's by doing it
um so for him it is a huge test but you
beat volkov man and we're going sizzler
tom where all the wine gums you can
[ __ ] handle you beat volkov dude
we're dude tea wine gums what the hell
you want man fish and chips we're going
dude
so i just
out of anyone i'm not worried about tom
asmanol being a father being a jiu jitsu
black belt his frame of mind i don't
think the moment's going to be too big
for him i think he's a feed off the
energy you just gotta hope a guy like
kim
and i don't think this can be the case i
am worried about some other london
fighters on the card but for a guy like
tom being a father being a little more
mature it's perfect timing but my god
did they give him a test in volkov
there's a reason he's an underdog i
still expect tom to beat him under three
rounds get a finish which is insane
because volkov has beat some of the very
[ __ ] best like for doom you know like
uh overeem he's a [ __ ] monster dude
you you look at him you know he beat
tiberia who's no punk lots of cyril gone
via decision who just fought for the
[ __ ] title beat aleister over him one
of the greatest strikes of all time
tko'd him in the second round walt
harris no punk athletic guy tko you know
him curtis blades decision uh greg hardy
decision um
you know derek lewis he had and then
lost
the third round uh basically end of
third round he got ko'd there beat
verdum
beaver doom that was in london uh he
beat struve beat roy nelson
you know
tough customer man tough night in the
office for him but for to have that
experience on be a minus 120 tells you
something there's there's a lot of
movement on tom aspinall but i just i
love you guys to come up you know i
don't think volkov ever be champ i think
he's had his run and it's tom's time and
i'm banking on that i'll put money on
tom
put my arnold allen um the guys you got
in arnold with that win streak this
moment's not gonna be big enough for him
i think he'll be fine the kid you gotta
worry about where the moment's gonna be
nuts he's never seen anything like this
is patty the baddie
you know he only has one fight he has
all this hype
seven-figure contract with bar stool
this we're gonna find out man you know
is he
the next coming of conor mcgregor he
checks all boxes uh they gave him a
great opponent and uh rodrigo vargas he
should beat var uh vargas i i would
imagine he's a big favorite jen let's
try i bet he's a minus three something
whoa minus four fifty minus four fifty
there you go
god that's even money on arnold allen
boy you put that parlay on them on the
british boys
telling you the the the the vegas isn't
uh taking consideration the power of an
english crowd man
arnold allen patty pembleton
you put tom aspinall three three three
fight parlay
you know
not mad at that at all dude our boy jack
shores an underdog plus 125 okay
i mean he has a tough fight very tough
fight
um but jack shorts can get it done
that's our boy king's sting alumni oh
yeah jack shore he's a savage man he's
he's underrated he's completely
underrated for him to be plus 125. i
know tomorrow's a [ __ ] monster but
jack short is good at everything he's
very good man
very good
yeah i'm just i'm banking on these
london boys getting it done man getting
it done
i know that london crowd is as well
uh krylov paul craig's phenomenal fight
gunner nelson uh
takashi is a good fight he's i mean this
car could easily be a pay-per-view man
easy ufc has given us a goddamn gift
here giving us a gift god dude what what
i mean jack shorten the prelims
come on dude
jai herbert got a tough tough day in the
office
not doing him any favors
great card though man i'm excited for it
gutter nelson finally coming back
i love this card man absolutely love
this card
but yeah those those last those last
three man those are those are what
people we're gonna be talking about
monday morning patty the baddie
obviously he's a huge favorite but just
the hype around him so patty the baddie
how how he's gonna get it done
uh rodrigo
you know he's uh he's a brawler hits
like a tank but i think we're gonna see
paddy's jiu jitsu which
you know his first fight he won uh via
knockout but you're gonna see a
submission i assume out of patty arnold
allen dan hooker stand up fight fight of
the night i think volkov tom aspinall
it's tough volca is a tough customer get
out of there man he's very very tough
but um i think we're gonna see tom
skills put to the test i think you'll
see um i'll say tom via submission in
that one
and volca is tough to take down but i
think tom gets it done
i can't wait for this card yeah so i get
pay-per-view it's early too which is
dope yeah
i love it two hours in and out boys do
work cowboys fight complain london
edition hauler
i love it man i can't wait to get on
tour back in [ __ ] england now things
are popping dude i cannot wait to go
there too and back in ireland
yes yeah nothing better
so that is at 1 p.m uh pacific time the
available on thick boy youtube and we
got a little extra hardware in here man
you can see it hell yeah thanks
from uh
from youtube they don't send it quick
we've been over a hundred thousand for a
little bit now they kind of take their
sweet time i'm sure they got a bunch of
awards to make but
so the way they do it now you get your
first plaque at a hundred thousand subs
i think about 130 000 now
and then your next plaque you don't get
to you hit a million so that's the goal
we have a long ways to go but that's the
goddamn shout out to the fans 100
percent
yeah fan driven you know we basically
launched thing in january right 130 000
now holler what's up dude what the hell
is up thank you guys love you guys got a
ways to go though the a million's the
goal here million is the goal
million is the goal that's what i want
for my birthday
we have four days of instruments right
now if we don't reach a million i quit
how about that
uh you had fights over the weekend
though too i had to watch these at six
a.m this morning with the time change
also the time change don't get me
started on it there's two things that we
have no control over it's this time
change [ __ ] where if you're a parent
you know exactly what i'm talking about
it's exhausting my son woke up at 7 30
which is usually 6 30 but 7 30. he has
to be at school by 8 30 you're rushing
out the doors poor kids are tired for
parents like suck it up get it done but
for kids it sucks man how long do we
keep doing this what are we doing
and then also my flight from [ __ ]
nashville was a nightmare i was supposed
to leave at 7 00 a.m flight got canceled
at a layover in dallas i get to dallas i
go okay well
my flight was delayed and you cancelled
that to you know the flight so i missed
the connecting flight to burbank and
like yeah we can get you out monday more
at 9am like that doesn't work for me
after work man that i have to be home
today like we don't have to tell you
they literally don't get
nothing there's nothing you can do but
laugh they're like cool [ __ ] fly
another airline we don't care because
they're just so busy they don't give a
flying hell they do not care so i had to
take i had to leave that airport to an
uber another airport 30 minutes away and
get on a southwest flight from dallas to
burbank nice how insane is that
american i was like i don't care what
you gonna do [ __ ] yeah you're right
i'll shut my mouth give me my points
though you know
uh yeah yeah you had fights this weekend
uh mvp and i i don't know if it's his
last one but um
you know cleo roundtree junior who i
absolutely love uh used to train with
khalil khalil was a guy who used to be
300 pounds used to sell fight gear
from i think the otm fight shop in uh
long beach or huntington beach
huntington beach he's still
at 300 pounds just to sell fight gear
there was any in shape start training he
was bullied as a kid he talks about it
um
i think he talked about this being one
of his last fight it might be his last
fight and he went full pride style and
just kick the show this guy ron waterman
h2o cro cop style and that's crow cop
kicking ron want him in the face but he
had the uh you know the demeanor not to
kick that in the head but oh my god that
kicks out [ __ ] vicious good way to go
out on your shield man shout out to cleo
roundtree i think we're getting that guy
in uh a food truck pretty soon here i
absolutely love khalil one of the
greatest guys doing it but this
interview here man how how do you not
love this [ __ ] guy play this game
sure and the fans can see and listen to
this yeah instagram
is a one
one question for you man um for the next
clue that's maybe sitting on his couch
right now a little bit overweight um
what's your message to them
you watch this you tell me you don't
love him it might sound a bit
cliche or we've heard this before but
like your life matters
your life matters
you can be special
you can be strong
you can be seen
you can be heard
life is beautiful
if you make it that way
it doesn't have to be
how everybody else makes it seem
stick around
stick around another day
i would have a lot of
a lot of things like that to say man
thank you absolutely
um yeah i mean i mean how do you not
love khalil after that he's just such a
good person man just such a good person
his journey is insane where he's at now
is insane dude he the discipline dude
i'm talking you know how your thick chin
you know we had that girl on your knee
during the
problem i was almost 300. yeah he was
300 dude and from that his body now he's
first team all bodies he's so ripped
it's such an inspirational story man
i mean this guy can go i don't know what
he wants to do i'll talk to him when we
get him here on it but
um
look at him man he looks
fantastic and that nuts it's crazy now
yeah
look at that look at that
let me do the amount think about the
amount of work it would take to get from
that to that
i mean he can go around doing
inspirational freaking talks the rest of
his life making crazy money if he wants
it's such a great story such a great
story tell me high schools colleges
aren't going to bring this kid in
it's amazing man yeah amazing boy he was
a thick kid yeah
look at him
he looks fantastic overweight teenager
turned ufc fighter from hard work
discipline dedication
shout out to khalil roundtree man unreal
dude on real transformation unreal
career
just to such an inspirational story man
that's why we got to get him on he's
your mvp yeah by far
boy drew dober got it done yeah
um you know in the main event santos and
magamet
magomed uh megamed is completely savage
he's fighting for a title for god's
sakes after this one he
with diego santos he's in a tough
position um i told you guys this um even
though i know thiago's fighting uh soon
him versus uh hill is the fight
i think for hill
santos for hill it's a great test and
santos obviously is a complete monster
um you know i don't know where he's at
injury-wise or suspension-wise i assume
60 days that fight makes a lot of sense
see where hill's at santos is a [ __ ]
savage they're gonna want to build hill
a way to do it is santos it's a great
matchup because he'll fancy himself a
striker has just that god-given knockout
ability in his hands santos is also hits
like a [ __ ] mack truck so i love that
fight for both gentlemen for a variety
of reasons
marlon marius lost that's tough that's
tough to see man
but yeah by the night no bonus awarded
but your mvp by far is khalil roundtree
come on what are we doing
and that dude uh alex paya the member
israel's the guy that beat israel twice
decision yeah unanimous
care for what you asked for he's gonna
keep winning he's gonna get this is he
um different game would be fun
um also kevin lee and diego sanchez they
fought i did see this one they both look
pretty good now kevin lee's gonna be out
a hot second he's a little injury prone
now you know he blew out his knee i
think he said blood is not if he blew it
out but he definitely injured him i
think he came out and said he tore it he
tore his knee up but diego sanchez i
think it's fair to say that that
weird coach was a huge liability diego
looked a hundred times better yeah way
better you can still do it man yeah i
you know i think even though diego lost
via decision uh unanimous which is the
right thing there but um you know diego
sanchez i think it shows you
that you know just how much that coach
would just suck in his energy and skill
set out he looks so much better yeah
khabib gave him a lot of praise too for
the fight he should
our boy ray borg won yep split decision
thank god always rooting for ray bork
hopefully his kiddo's okay
good for khabib man first one in america
big big success yeah they got some new
signings i'll show you later too all
right yeah this is a bellator a ton of
but adam borick's who's a monster phil
dave is still doing the goddamn thing
phil dave's a gitch in them decisions
yeah good luck being killed decision
matt yeah he loves some judges they had
one championship as well or gary tony
root for complete savage jutsu got ko'd
bad yeah he almost had he almost had one
of those heel hook things whatever but
then he got killed bad yeah it's bad
yeah john lineker is complete [ __ ]
savage over that one championship k.o
second round
yeah yeah tough to see gary tony go out
like that
yeah i think him and also ryan hall you
know ryan hall the kevin florence dude
he there i guess they've been going back
and forth before and then ryan i think
ryan hall knows this guy tom lee yeah so
he was like giving him praise but also
kind of talk sort of a little bit
smackdown
and then and then gary turner went back
and then reinhardt kind of apologized
after that yeah because he's not a [ __ ]
talking no it's not his nature also when
a guy gets knocked out i know it's a
tough one
a quick update on king velasquez
so one of the judges which is basically
everyone knows it's pretty much the main
judge that didn't want to give him bail
yeah she didn't seem too friendly yeah
so i guess she's getting threats now so
she's hired asking for more security and
everything else oh yeah yeah kane's
beloved man yes mexican community to
enjoy that judge
but obviously you know these judges this
is the first time they've dealt with
some
threats stuff like that they're pretty
protected uh you don't see that also it
doesn't do kane any favors when you're
making threats to the judge don't do
that what happens is
she's not a ufc fan clearly
i would be willing to imagine if you
asked or should call it [ __ ] fighting
still that's the you know
the kind of her perspective on this
stuff um
yeah when she says you know doesn't give
kane bail and she's concerned about
safety and you know she wants protection
this is this only hurts kane's chances
you gotta hope he goes to jury man yeah
i really do because this judge is doing
him no favors it's so sad to see dude i
don't i don't know what to make of it
yeah let's pray for the best
um this is great you already knew this
though but chandler versus tony ferguson
yeah
six
says may seventh phoenix may 7th we have
fight campaign i think bus with the bros
are flying in for that oh sick
because they're cool with the uh they're
really close to chandler on their show
because i was supposed to do the super
ball with them which would have made
more sense right because they're
football players but then uh you know i
had a great opportunity with tyson and
dc and brandon marshall so i had to do
that so i had to cancel on them which
they gave me a lot of [ __ ] for
uh so i was like no dude i'm telling you
next one like all right what about april
mccarran well that one's not gonna work
but let's do may because chandler fights
on that you guys know chandler so then
come out for that may uh seventh one in
phoenix because yeah they're huge fans
of chandler
that and that you know my chandler
ferguson i absolutely love the fight
yeah love the fight
love love love the fight great fight who
do you got
chandler yeah for sure right you know
tony's following some tough times
[Music]
uh and here's the card so far it's
looking dope
so yeah main event for may 7th card is
charles oliveira justin gaichy banger
chandler tony ferguson banger shogun osb
seen it
donald cerrone joe lauzon oh two legends
going at it
uh
okay we got some is and this this
brandon roy val's fantastic yeah
that's the whole card chaos williams is
always fun
that's the main card let me um that's
the main card i said that's the whole
thing so far so let me see one two keep
going down chin
so they're banking uh okay yeah the top
two those first two fights are great and
then it gets you know a little dicey but
then you have big names in cerrone joe
lozan two vets going at it
i would assume they add one more big
name because i think uh
[Music]
yeah chaos and randy brown's a great
fight too but yeah for sure the top two
because if the main card would be yeah
title charles justin
co chandler ferguson
third fight though he's tossing as a fun
one you got shogun osb okay i'll watch
it
cerrone
lauzon i would assume i thought that
would be the main event on like the
prelims yeah
we'll see it's still let me take my
money yeah let me take my money it's
still early but take my money
um okay so robert whitaker posted
something that made it sound like he
might go down back to welterweight may i
tell him that's what i want for him
uh-huh so this is what he wrote
on twitter skinny rob might be coming
back sooner than i wanted
but then turns out he'll be fighting or
that they're targeting
him versus marvin victoria for ufc 275 i
like that yeah i like it daddy like
daddy like
and he's open for that huh yeah june
11th pay-per-view
expect take place in singapore enjoy
that singapore flag and that singapore
one is also where they moved the yuri
prashka and glover takes sarah fight you
know that one time
and here
ali abdelaziz says that oozman could
knock out canola alvarez in
three rounds and i'll just play this
game you want a manager like that you
know you want to imagine my my manager
thinks i'm the next kevin hart you know
that's what you want that's what you
want
he didn't want to fight jake paul he'd
want to fight logan paul he said i'm the
pound for pound king and mma i want to
fight the pound the pound for pound
cower and box them because i think those
boxers are cowards because none of them
want to come to mma they all want to
come to boxing right but at the end of
the initial they
who's the baddest man on the planet they
cannot call canelo the badest man on the
planet they cannot call canelo the bis
the pound-four-pound piss boxer because
if they both made him a street who's
gonna win camaro beat his ass like he's
told something listen at the end of the
day um you know this is what he wants
you want to fight canelo uh in september
you know what this is a different
conversation first he have to defend his
title in july and the greatest promoter
of all the time mr dana white have to
stamp on it and we will not do any
things
uh in box or anything without dana
because
my opinion he's the greatest promoter of
all the time i agree
how do you think he would do because i
mean a lot of people are saying you know
canelo's the greatest in boxing of
course
we can all agree that camaro would just
run through him but unboxing i mean do
you do you give him a chance camaro
knock him out in three rounds do you
really think so i do i do so you know
listen you cannot say no to the camaro
you cannot say no to camaro he's a guy
who's come from africa
i mean listen you again you want a
manager like this and i love ali he
writes for his guys he's one of the best
managers in the game but
uh
you know that's what he's gonna to say
for dana even with francis tyson fury
james like i don't like that fight for
tyson i don't either i like to get that
he's gonna get [ __ ] you money it's a
very tough fight for tyson uh
francis is more likely to beat tyson
than camaro's canelo avarice you know
those the the lower you go in those
weight classes
the dicer it gets those guys are so
[ __ ] talented man
um
for dana you gotta wonder
you know obviously
connor landed some punches on uh floyd
like i promise you guys can guaranteed
you and bet max kellerman 100 grand he
didn't want to take the money whatever
because he said he wouldn't land a punch
and i issued a bet to him and he was
like i don't make this public good
absolutely not like that makes sense but
um
for dana you know i i don't know if you
want your ufc guys getting beat by all
these boxers you know i
you know for the casual fan it's a bit
of a black guy
let's be honest you know was conor going
to be does he have puncher's chance
against floyd sure
uh
francis definitely has a puncher's
chance [ __ ] tough to do you know
camaro
verse you know canelo camaro just
started to get you know his his hands
together he knocked out moswed all right
um
you know he i i would assume kamal vs
canelo would be the biggest underdog of
all time as far as mma to boxing he'd be
a bigger undog than floyd connor
begundog than uh
francis tyson fury it would be the
toughest
goal to achieve so
but again i like it when guys get it it
gives us a something to talk about
b these guys get [ __ ] you money that's
why i want them to get i hope this fight
happens yeah tomorrow because you get
generational wealth it's the only place
you're gonna get it you're not gonna get
in the ufc unless you're the next conor
i don't think they're ever gonna allow
another conor to happen because he has
too much power um so i hope camaro gets
this fight i canelo is such a purist
when it comes this like he hates jake
paul he hates logan paul he hates all
that [ __ ] i just don't see canelo doing
it
unless
you know they say hey here's the money
could make you just got to beat up this
mma i think man like all right let's do
it
so it might could be a money play but
camaro out of i'm sorry canelo out of
everyone's the most purest guy
he sometimes you know he's all set on
money so
unless it's a money play you know
canelo's such a purist and doesn't
really entertain this [ __ ] he's
always hated it he's always frowned upon
on it so we'll see
but it would be by far the toughest task
of all time because canelo's not past
his prime he's not a whatever 46 year
old
smaller fighter like floyd is with
connor the big boy
still
in his prime still doing at the highest
level is the pound-for-pound king of
boxing
top fight for camaro yeah but i want it
to happen just even if we get starched
in 30 seconds you still get [ __ ] you
money that's all i want for tomorrow
if i'm chasing the exact same thing dude
yeah that's exactly what i'm doing and
canelo did kind of reply to a reporter
he said like when they asked him about
the uzman fight he goes he said payday
simple
yeah you know if you're if you're
canelo's camp and you're you side on the
side of canelo which i tend to do here
um
it's an easy day yeah office for him
come on i don't care though
so ham's out your boy um posted
something after kamara kept talking
about him wanting to fight canoe alvarez
and this is what he posted
so he goes he's a good boxer
and then crying laughing emoji
what's the video
just very simple oh just him getting
wild and be knocked out
i know i'm sorry
he
knocked him out bad
that's a weird one yeah
have you have you been seeing the stuff
uh gilbert uh burns has been talking to
hamzat but then he's fake he posts some
videos saying that it's a lie and like
fake and the size and all the stuff i'm
so curious
there's one day ago michael
uh
so i'll finish comes out in second or
third round interesting
[Music]
i'll go there take the guy out with a
punch boom knock out all right
i think hanzo is very tough he's very
good let's be honest he's never seen one
of grappling wise juju striking speed
experience
um
yeah he's saying something about him how
he doesn't believe something
or maybe it's that click click on
michael pierre or yeah this one
i'm thought not this must be we've
created especially the real
hamzad against gilbert burns oh so
that's michelle i know something i don't
know
i don't think he's this much brave
created we'll see the real uh humps out
in the gilbert fight that's what we'll
see who's the real hot homs that but as
fighters we kind of see who's who's who
a little bit he might surprise but he's
not that that better than gilbert hamzad
is good but he hasn't faced top
competition yet i'm gonna see if he's
the man against but i don't see all that
danger people talk about really
interesting i know that's all i see
right i mean
terrifying yeah okay
cool
uh quick fight night announcement or
yeah ooh that's a fun one yeah rob font
and cheetah boy cheeto yep
headlines ufc fight night event april
30. that's a great [ __ ] fight
great fight definitely a great fight
maz vidal posted this about his eye
and colin kobe a cheater right
and you'll see this picture right here
it goes almost took my eyes out but all
good you cheating [ __ ] see you soon but
then people were giving them crap
because it's not that's not like a
pokemon that's not bad and then yeah so
people were she's gotta take this loss
dude i know
that's not bad at all and then someone
this one i liked you sure wasn't from
this
[Laughter]
sure it wasn't from this punch to the
face
yeah you know might as well do a
mozzarella thing gotta love them
uh we mentioned francis ingano so
uh markell he said that he's gonna have
the surgery this week that means a nine
month recovery so basically out all year
suffered a torn mcl and damaged acl so
yeah so recovery is nine months it's
perfect while they're you know while
they're figuring out his deal dfc the
fury fight i have no issue with it
i would assume they do uh interim belt i
think steve bay jon jones fights this
summer and it's up for enter belt
that'd be a dope fight i bet you that's
what the ufc does
um actually i should jump to that right
now then so
here we go
tai tuv also says he wants to fight with
stipe
yeah i get it you know steve bannon
yeah he's going straight for the top if
i'm thai i also love that didn't we
order the tai shui oh they just messaged
me that they shipped it like a day ago
from from yeah
probably new zealand australia all right
it's gonna take a while all right it's
an international thing we'll replace the
kanye shoe with that
uh it's definitely so this is uh thai
talking it's definitely a fight that i
think should be up next especially it's
the fight i want i think the other guys
around the clock i think we're gonna be
around for a few more years out of
respect i think we'd love to share a
ring with him and i think i'm up
there for a chance of it so why not he's
a great fighter someone i've watched for
many years so when i definitely love the
challenge against myself
um you know as
we had chael on the show last week he's
talking about how big
stephen has gotten the muscle he's put
on give me a prom man stephen's a bad
mama jama
but the i i highly doubt the ufc gives
it to ty two of us who absolutely love
and i'd love to fight and that is a very
tough fight for tai uh switzerland comes
to the wrestling grappling of uh stipe
unless he can land early but uh
the fight is is steep a john jones
there's nobody else john should come
back and fight i'd rather see that fight
me too i'm sorry
uh just for the hell of it the these are
the uh opening odds if they ever
actually fight and i thought it'd be way
you know minus 220 yeah that's just a
lot higher the quote-unquote experts not
knowing what version of stipe we're
going to get but when you find out he's
put on all this weight
it's a very tough fight for taito vasa
yeah
all right um greg hardy we kind of saw
this coming but he was released from the
ufc except three fights in a row that he
lost yeah pretty badly too so yeah i saw
the post good picture but what a run
your boy is far from done just got some
fine tuning to do you got all the tune
to do my man and you know i enjoy his
fights we got all the tuning to do thank
you all my fans and haters appreciate
you almost i appreciate my coaches
family in the ufc giving me the
opportunity to shine bright yeah
good good send off you know i i doubt he
ever gets back to the ufc
too much work to be had
yeah they gave him a lot of
opportunities too for sure you know for
what he was doing you know his fight
against uh volkov in the decision late
replacement
you know
all right jake paul posted this
obviously this is so interesting to me i
wonder if dana's even going to entertain
it because what when i heard jake paul
office when you see him like jesus
christ jake
then you read it you're like
if i'm dana i'm like
yeah definitely do it so this is jake
paul's tweet to dana although he didn't
go at dana white which is interesting
but dana since you like me now how about
a one fight ufc deal to fight conor if i
win you agreed to my ufc fighter payne
healthcare proposal which is interesting
if i lose i donate my entire purse to
all the ufc fighters who make less than
50k a fight never mention ufc again deal
you gotta do it got it god it's tasty
yeah
i mean if i'm dana's a business first
things first he is a businessman this
would be a banger on the ufc
pay-per-view
connor jake paul
and also
connor probably a plot or i'm sorry a
minus 1800 like the odds on your sign mr
white why not do it dude yeah
but let's see what if conor actually
lost would just be impo i'm almost
impossible what if he actually lost the
the the the hold up is gonna be you know
the ufc fighter pay and healthcare
proposal i don't know what his proposal
was but i'm sure the ufc is like dude we
got to do what
but yeah the chance of him being conor
in the mma ring is you know not good
yeah
but i watched it like it was pretty fair
and usually makes so much i know it'd be
such a huge fight yeah because jake paul
is going to be around like you know this
isn't a five-year plan for jake man
i love it
same i would do it yep
all right uh bryce mitchell's been
pretty much everywhere now he actually
appeared on tucker carlson's show
it's been i love it
i'll play some of this real quick it's
on twitter so we should be able to use
it
so of all the people you've seen weigh
in on ukraine maybe none has put the
american position does tucker crosston
not look like the dad off rick and morty
he looks identical to him dude
this guy yes
that's tucker carlson dude
he he just looks like such a cartoon
all right play cartoon yes
more succinctly or expressed it more
wisely than a man called grace mitchell
we played a portion of his comments on
this shirt
farmer
last week he was asked what do you think
about ukraine and here's part of what he
said
i'm not going nowhere to fight none of
these wars for these politicians i'm
staying at home and when the war comes
to arkansas i will dig my boots in the
ground and i will die for every positive
category daddy likes daddy likes but
also russia's not getting invade uh
alabama or the [ __ ] is that you know but
or arkansas i like it i like it
but you know i have to dig your boots
down russia's not trying to take over
arkansas my man keep going
dana white's pretty good with how he
lets us uh
talk and say what we want
that is that is absolutely right and a
fair thing to say now people who say
what you have said
are often denounced as unpatriotic how
many fights is
i will fight and die
for arkansas
that'd be the greatest honor i could
ever have brother so i'm i'm both from
uh not being a patriot you know that'd
be the greatest thing i could do is die
defending this land so i'm not afraid to
do that i'm just not wanting to go waste
my life fighting for some of these
battles that i don't even believe in i
you know where i believe our
leaders a lot of these elites are guilty
of trees and what they've done is just
uh treasonous and
you know and i'm sure you know what i'm
talking about a little bit
it it's it's funny that they're accusing
you of treason um why do you think
almost everyone in the media and i mean
almost everybody and both political
parties and of course the white house
are all on the same page that you need
to get behind this war with russia why
is that so important to them do you have
any sense
well i don't exactly know what their
agenda is with the whole war on russia
but i do know that um all that money
that's going to the biden family through
hunter biden
he's not he doesn't have the merit for
that position he's got over there
they've used our tax dollars to bribe
him a job you know um if me or you did
what nancy pelosi did and got millions
in stocks we'd go to prison for insider
trading but she does it daddy like
their families are getting
um
very
greatly compensated while they're taxing
us to death inflation's higher than ever
they close down all of our pipelines and
wonder why the price of oil
has gone through the roof
these people are trying to destroy our
country because they are profiting off
the downfall of our country and if you
all don't see what's going on you are
blinded every day
you know our inflation gets worse our
debt gets worse
um
basically tucker agreed with 100
you know i i like his message i i ride
with a lot of that
i i do think if i'm bryce which is what
he's doing i'm not telling anything his
team doesn't know or he doesn't know
he's clearly leaning into this you know
kind of
the right side here which is a huge fan
base and you know for colby colby did
the same thing whether now
the difference between colby and bryce's
bryce is actually
educated and aware of this kobe's doing
100 as a heel in the wwe bryce
you can have an actual
geo political conversation with i think
he knows a thing or two about it where
he's getting his information i don't
know but clearly he's educated he's
reading about that yeah so
you know i'm i've [ __ ] with bryce
mitchell man i like bryce mitchell yeah
it's very entertaining as well
uh so he also has the skills to back it
up listen he's not on there if he's not
winning five yeah i don't care what you
believe in you're not on there unless
you're winning fights exactly
uh so faders his retirement fight was
supposed to be in moscow at the red
square but obviously it was supposed to
be this summer too but obviously because
everything's going on
they're going to try to find another
location for it
interesting but it's still going to be
fedor yeah his retirement fight
so this is scott coker the president of
uh
bellator almost did strikeforce the
president of bellator said we had an
amazing show playing moscow i don't even
mind telling you guys this but we
originally had approval to do the fight
in the red square and it was going to be
just a great send-off for the goat in my
opinion but now we have a half to pivot
you know [ __ ] and create something else
that's great and find another venue and
find another amazing site because he
deserves to have a great send-off we
just know exactly where yet
that's interesting so if it's around
here
and they did the matt mitchell fight
that would be that would be cool or or
josh barnett oh yeah josh burnett today
of course
yeah we'll see
i mentioned before the eagle fc signed
some new people mm-hmm so they signed
hector bel uh hector lombard oh wow and
he's fighting remember thiago silva yeah
from way back and they're gonna fight
each other yeah they're in the same camp
for years oh really yeah holy crap
silver's mr att back in the day dr
lombard's mr att
that's fun yeah good for you
to beat
wow and where's that going down
um hold on one sec
and uh
dig or
damn they're picking up some big names
yeah remember this happened too
yeah yeah something happened with you
know domestic stuff but
maybe he left you know what i'm thinking
of um
sorry the flare-up of uh ct
um thiago alves oh y'all got alves
that's my bad yeah yeah yeah thiago
silva he was scary when he first came
out he just looked like a killer savage
yeah
but like you said junior just snatched
us as well wow
um you go eagle fc doing the guy yeah
they're science and actually i love it
man good for khabib dude
uh this is just an interesting fact so
when conor visited
was he in russia he went to some
fifa thing a world cup okay i think he
was part yeah almost like so in moscow
in 2018 and he gifted uh putin
a proper 12 bottle he said their
security team had to actually get the
bottle pour some of that out and test it
to make sure it wasn't poisoned
yeah even though yeah of course yeah
yeah i mean if you're putting that's the
[ __ ] you got to do
[Music]
and another thing on this whole russia
stuff paul acosta tweeted something out
and then deleted it and i'll show you
what he tweeted
well this is uh from paulo costa not me
this is me
apollo costa tweet about vladimir putin
i think vladimir as well vladimir putin
uh he's put putin twice that's cool
vladimir putin putin is not a weak
leader like biden or macron he's a
former military man who's already been
stabbed in the belly and survived he's
another level of world leaders do you
know another leader who has the same
character oh well
yeah yeah obviously you got like again
okay listen for some of these mma guys
when they talk about politics i wish you
didn't if you knew the
horrible [ __ ] clearly just turn on the
news they're killing killing pregnant
women innocent children murdering kids
bombing daycare centers bombing
hospitals theo uh what was his [ __ ]
name oh cos the holocaust you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about you
have no clue dude to tweet something
like that you got to be a goddamn [ __ ]
a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
but yeah but again these guys you want
to talk about like you have any idea
what you're talking about co-signing
putin
just pick up a god damn book man watch
the news you can't co-sign this [ __ ]
devil talking about a really bad dude
responsible for thousands of lives man
you have millions of people looking for
safety and refugee what the [ __ ] are you
doing
i know you don't know you don't know
yeah so
at least you deleted it
i'm sure the ufc was like hey [ __ ]
yeah we can't book you a fight if you're
gonna [ __ ] rock a putin shirt
scott coker reacts to kylie harrison we
signed with pfl uh pfl i don't know who
she's gonna fight over there so yeah
bellator did put the money but then pfl
matched it so she's staying with pfl
right now
yeah i don't know i don't know what i
don't know how long her contract is it's
you know
if you want to be the you know the
biggest baddest
on the small playground you know and
there's nothing wrong with pfl that's
fine you know it's easy payday you're
not taking damage and you're the most
dominant
fighter ever in pfl that's cool
[Music]
we all know in this room it doesn't
countless in ufc
like legacy history like if there's a
guy who averaged 50 points a game but
was playing in you know overseas
is he gonna say he's the best basketball
player when we have lebron and kevin
durant no because we know the toughest
competition is here it's in the united
states it's in the nba
the ufc is the nba the ufc's the nfl if
uh if a quarterback throws for 10 000
yards and you know the cfl sweet dude
come try your hand with the big boys
you know like she knows you know
but again i don't know her personal
kind of goals and financial goals and
stuff like that that million bucks a
year she gets every time she beats the
[ __ ] out of all these girls in the pfl
because there's no competition
so manager uh puts kylie harrison in the
top the highest paid female athlete of
all time lists and then so they paid her
more
ronda rousey had a base pay of three
million plus supposedly around one point
eight million pay-per-view cut does mean
kylie harrison new pfl deal exceeds that
4.8 million total if he means just
highest ever base paid does she get more
than 3 million per fight now
big claims but again without any
specifics i spoke with harrison's
manager ali who said the pfl stepped up
in a big way kyla is now the highest
paid women's mixed emotional artist ever
god she's making more than i know is
that possible man
i don't know
and it was a while ago here's the thing
if she did get that deal where she's
getting more than three million
to fight the you know the lower
competition i
might have to say yes too i don't know
they i'm sure that just back up the
brink trucks to to keep her around
but just as a business opportunity
there's no way pfl is translating that
into sales they don't have pay-per-views
uh it's very i don't i don't know i i
as a fan of kyla i i
would love to see her in the ufc
i think she could have made more money
in the ufc you over the the grand scheme
of her career than she would whatever
the pfl i don't care even as three
million flat she'd make more in the fc
in the long run because i think she'd be
on defeat in the ufc as well mm-hmm
and all the
the sponsorships
you know the outside dock gun
sponsorships the you know the toyo tires
the bud light
you know brain energy monster all this
[ __ ] yeah
she knows what she's doing though huge
fan of her she's a monster definitely a
monster
i'm so curious what the deal was though
uh so paige van zandt is now signed with
aew
the wrestling organization pro wrestling
good for her yeah i think that's like
that's the move you know that's the move
mma and bkfc has been tough on her man i
don't want to see you get punched in the
face and if she can take her fan base
and go over to you know pro wrestling
god bless you girl yeah
uh there's a quick one i didn't really
know this girl but so valentina
shochenko has a new opponent another oh
santos is tough yeah santos is a [ __ ]
sound yeah
she in fight that's for the ufc
man yeah she's tough 1901 yeah she's
very tough
and lost via split decision i thought
she won that fight whatever
but definitely okay that's a great tough
fight for chef janko
so um
obviously we're banking on this fight to
happen right so ufc london main card it
seems like everything's still good to go
but you never know because it's you know
the whole russian icy over there yeah so
but as of right now volkov and i think
all the other russian fighters are still
in the card mm-hmm yeah
um this is justin poirier responding to
colby covington chris copeland called
called him out after he fought maldridal
no uh
pory wants that once the fight with dean
yeah that's what he wants with nate
so he's cute um it's all good it is what
is people want big fights that's a big
fight he wants a big fight he said big
fight way too many times justin aussie
he's not in line for the title fight he
lost twice the champ so he's probably
needs a few more wins i think one uh but
i would think if you want to get back to
strap you've got to fight welterweight
contenders i don't know what i'm doing
if i'm going to welterweight if i'm
staying at 55 we'll see it is what it is
okay
yeah and then he also said
uh he's not making money off my name
it's still on site you [ __ ] sheep
okay and then he deleted it
yes he said he wants to fight him but
just not in the cage he wants to fight
on the street come on party get paid
don't be that guy
all righty
um all right let's go to
check this crap out this is so this is a
brave mma
and uh
someone did that
i don't know what kind of call kick it's
called but you'll see it question mark
kick no it's when you when you flip and
you hit hit
but you hit the ref okay miscalculated
it should be on ridiculousness not em
oh my goodness
he actually he got back up and started
continuing to officiating gangster yeah
he straight up guy yeah he had like on
the chin too yeah
but that was good and the same
um clearly event
a problem the ref gets hit here too no
no this ref is [ __ ] is super dope watch
you'll see this
um
so there's about to be a brawl that
happened and the ref check out how
strong this referee is
that is a legend that is not a legend oh
he's talking [ __ ] to the coaches
legend that is a champ champ that that's
all you just keep them out of there
there you go keep them out of it push
them back over muhammad [ __ ] with dean
oh wow somebody else trying to get in
the brave combat federation cage
cause a little bit of trouble
here comes another shot
muhammad
there it is holy [ __ ] dude sign him up
for guard on the denver broncos
oh wow what up he's so strong that guy's
awesome yeah
uh
aaron wallace is his name the referee
well that was chaos
yeah uh this is just some sexy yama
posts yeah that's his fashion right
there when he uh god mr swag
and then check out this video of him
best back ever
i mean flawless daddy
look at the muscles on that thing
flawless
god dawg
just that gold skin yeah
wow his back is not crazy right
that boy is fine yeah give him that and
this one i just saw that was pretty cool
yeah mckenzie thank you for hanging out
yep she's crushing it
yeah and that's all for current events
those are good thanks for ending on that
that is fantastic uh
yeah fight night london this saturday 1
p.m pacific we have the calabasas fight
companion london crew coming up
jeff dye crystallize myself that is at 1
pm on thick boy network youtube watch it
live with your boys get your pints get
your wine gums whatever you got to do we
rolling baby at 1 p.m thick boy this
freaking saturday
i can't wait for that man and i do want
to thank the fans we breezed by it but
you know getting the
the plaque for 100k followers is a big
deal man subscribers so we're not going
to stop till we get to million and uh
that's the plan and we're on track we're
on track baby um outside that
next show shop and friends los angeles
california march 23rd at the hollywood
improv we had some monsters there last
weekend we're doing again last one in
march 8 pm show one show only la
hollywood improv we back and boom in la
baby and then chicago haven't been there
in a hot freaking second i got the most
litty jacket you've ever seen for that
chicago show i've been waiting to buy
this goddamn jacket finally have a
reason i'm in chicago march 24th through
the 26th that is next thursday friday
saturday schaumburg improv right outside
chicago but we're calling it chicago
come get some chicago i can't wait i'm
gonna be rocking my ryan sandberg jersey
and uh that is chicago next week
thursday friday saturday chicago that's
a big boy venue so let's freaking go
chicago wins
and then phoenix arizona stand up live
april 14th through 16th
end of april i have a big announcement
uh your boy's part of a pretty big
economy festival i'm headlining so
that's a big deal
get your tickets at f a tkz.com or
thickboy.com
on thickboy.com we just dropped the uh
thick mudder tees you can pre-order them
right now the thick mudder tees you will
get them well in time before the the
thick mudder which is april 9th 10 30
we're offering a 5k if you're scared for
the 15k but there's a 5k and 15k
um get the shirt run with the boys uh
and gals that's the thick mudder team
get it right now if you order it this
week you're definitely getting it before
the tough mudder april 9th at 10 30 a.m
if you go to the tough mudder site
you'll see the thick mudder there it's
at 10 30 a.m
thick mudder my face is all over the
goddamn thing enter the promo code thick
boy you get 10 off when you sign up
which actually saves you a lot of money
so uh get you some man
get you some the tough mudder is nothing
better it's so much fun uh 15k
and 5k for those of you want to take a
little easy we have the 5k for you too
so um that's it man
um what do we got this week got anything
out we dropped anything this week we had
a
flashback fight nights or we had the
flashback fight nights with uh michael
chandler dropped we had the food truck
michael chandler that dropped um and
then we'll have some we got we gotta
shoot two food trucks this week busy
week guys and it's the b day week i love
you guys thank you so much for
subscribing if you haven't subscribed or
liked yet go do it right now
also uh king the sting and the wing
we're on patreon now you get two
episodes and all the other episodes ad
free that's cats plus on patreon sign up
right now that thing is booming baby so
we love you guys thank you so much um
but next up chicago let's ride next week
thursday friday saturday chicago come
get some tickets at thickboy.com or
fatkz.com
thank you for watching enjoy the fights
london i love you let's blow the
freaking roof off that o2 arena uh the
boys are back london is back cowbest
fight companion london version is going
down saturday 1 p.m thick boy only love
you guys stay thick stay safe
see you next time